hey was geht ab und bekommen bei einem
neuen video hier mal wieder auf meinem
kanal ja was heißt video obwohl ein
video ist es ja im endeffekt schon
allerdings handelt es sich heute mal
wieder um so ein tag und zwar bin ich
dadurch den tim auch zum richtig coolen
tag gestoßen werden wir auch relativ gut
gefällt und dieser tag nennt sie einfach
intime fragen wie der name schon sagt
geht es um etwas intimere fragen und ich
weiß nicht so einfach anderen werdet ihr
es ganze schon verstehen was so der sinn
dieses tages ist ob die fragen jetzt so
super intim sind oder vielleicht auch
nicht so wirklich super intim da will
ich jetzt meine frage ich würde sagen
wir fangen jetzt direkt mal anschaut
sich an und dann werdet ihr ja schon so
für euch selber ermitteln können ob das
jetzt in teams keine ahnung
los geht's
frage nummer eins hast du haustiere
nee ich habe keine haustiere ich habe
mir als ich klein war aber mal eine
katze gewünscht die habe ich aber leider
nie bekommen
worüber ich jetzt auch relativ froh bin
aber sonst hunde finde ich eigentlich
coolen wenn ich jetzt ein hund bekommen
könnte würde ich sagen gerne ich nehme
gerne und auch wenn man sich da viel
darum kümmern muss mache ich natürlich
ne naja nächste frage
lerne drei dinge die gerade in deiner
nähe sind handy sofa und fenster wie ist
das wetter gerade bei dir ich hab mir
direkt so ein schönes großes fenster
wodurch mich die leute auch immer
beobachten können wenn ich gerade videos
drehen haben wir zumindest schon mal so
manche welche gesagt ich hab mich da
gesehen
auf jeden fall ist das wetter so für
einen februar relativ gut die sonne
scheint so ein ganz kleines bisschen und
ansonsten kalt ist es jetzt nicht
hast du einen führerschein nee ich hab
leider noch keinen führerschein ich bin
ja auch gerade 16 geworden bzw
vor ein paar monaten oder so auf jeden
fall habe ich erst so vor den mit 17
anzufangen also ich habe keinen
führerschein
wann bist du heute aufgestanden ich
musste heute schule und zur schule stehe
ich immer um 57 auf das heißt heute bin
ich komischerweise auch und finden nach
sie immer aufgestanden wann hast du das
letzte mal geduscht
also bei mir es immer so morgens habe
ich nicht zu duschen weil ich immer so
spät aufstehen und die schule dann schon
fast direkt beginnt deswegen nur die
meistens abends so um 10 uhr das heißt
gestern abend um 10 uhr habe ich das
letzte mal geduscht was war der letzte
film den du gesehen hast
ich war letztens im kino vor zwei wochen
oder eineinhalb wochen
und da waren wir in diesem wolf of wall
street oder so da ging irgendwie vier
stunden lang und nach einer stunde war
schon langweilig also den fand ich jetzt
nicht so atemberaubend also geht auf
keinen fall in der scheiße wie hört sich
deinen klingelton an
oder wo kaufst du deine lebensmittel
also als 16-jähriger ist man jetzt nicht
so dazu verpflichtet für seine familien
die lebensmittel zu kaufen
aber wenn ich mir irgendwas kaufen dann
kauf ich dort meistens im mini preis
falls ihr dort kennt keine ahnung wie
viele geschwister hast du ich habe einen
bruder
mehr nicht hast du einen computer oder
ein notebook
ja ich habe ein computer und er steht
immer genau da also hinter der kamera
aus eurer sicht links genau er steht
immer genau da auf eurer sicht links
keine ahnung ob ihr euch jetzt so
kompliziert denken könnt um
herauszufinden wo mein computer steht
aber ist jetzt eigentlich nebensache
wie alt wirst du an deinem nächsten
geburtstag ich bin jetzt 16 das heißt an
meinem nächsten geburtstag werde ich im
trägst du eine brille oder kontaktlinsen
ich sehr heftig aus wie eine fliege
gerade kann das sein
ansonsten manchmal tragen sonnenbrillen
das war jetzt voll coole aktion sonne
bestimmt also manchmal gerne
sonnenbrille im sommer ansonsten trägt
keine brille weil ich auch so gut sehen
können
herbst du dir die haare ja klar also
normalerweise habe ich rot aber das habe
ich jetzt halt beim friseur bisschen so
blond oder dunkelblond gefärbt alle zwei
monate kommt das gut an wieder ein
bisschen durch das heißt ich muss das
umfärben aber nein natürlich nicht also
das ist meine natur haarfarbe und mit
der laufer aus seitdem ich klein bin rum
es sei dann ist es sommer dann werden
immer heller was planst du für den
heutigen tag
ich habe gleich noch training und
ansonsten heute abend kommt noch meine
freundin war ja heute eigentlich der
valentinstag ist auch wenn ich das video
erst morgen hochladen am samstag aber
was ist der perfekte pizzabelag für dich
gar keiner
als ich als pizza margherita am liebsten
oder manchmal wieder sorgt so wenn ich
eine pizza ab dann war ich so ein
bisschen den belag runter und es sie mit
apfelkompott oder apfelmus
das war irgendwie voll gerne
was magst du mehr hamburger und
cheeseburger eigentlich cheeseburgern
der käse bei majors und burger king ist
irgendwie voll geil finde ich und
deswegen beschädigt merke ich immer ein
cheeseburger was du je länger als einen
ganzen tag 24 stunden wach das irgendwie
doppelt gemoppelt war je länger als
einen ganzen tag 24 stunden bach - das
passt schon
das patent für eine frage wer war denn
bitte noch nicht länger als 24 stunden
wach ja also mein längstes war so 40
stunden würde ich sagen ihr müsst den
kommen kannst du pepsi von cola
unterscheiden
natürlich kann ich also beides irgendwie
extrem gerne im kino trinkt man immer
pepsi glaube ich und ansonsten cola
trinke ich auch gerne aber es ist mir
eigentlich relativ egal ob ich jetzt
gerade pepsi trinke oder cola weil ist
fast gleich menge leute das war's jetzt
doch leider schon wieder mit dem video
und bzw mit diesem tag und ich hoffe
natürlich er hat euch gefallen oder es
hat euch gefallen wie man es auch immer
sieht video tag ist ja eigentlich auch
scheißegal
auf jeden fall wenn es euch gefallen es
gibt natürlich allgemein daumen nach
oben wenn sie nicht ganz so gefallen hat
natürlich auch einfach daumen nach oben
und schaut doch mal in der beschreibung
dort stehen die ganzen fragen wenn ihr
mal bock habt diesen tag auch zu machen
dann machten doch einfach und das video
vom team der den tag auf gemacht hat ist
natürlich auch und in der video
beschreibung könnt ihr auch mal
vorbeischauen und schon mio ach ja und
wenn ihr absolut nichts mehr verpassen
wechsler verpassen wollt dann abonniert
doch einfach den kanal wird mich auf
jeden fall freuen wenn ihre nabu da last
so leute hier unten geht es jetzt weiter
mit zwei von meine letzte videos auf
jeden fall findet hier unten rechts
einmal den golf renntag mit meiner
freundin das war mein letztes video und
hier unten irgend links meinen ersten
tag den ich auf meinem channel gemacht
habe das war der erste mal tech und high
tech die beschreibungen ab für instagram
facebook und so weiter könnte ja mal
vorbeischauen und ansonsten wünsche euch
noch ein schönes wochenende hatte rheine